okay well first things first
freaks all the honey
he's playboy bunnies
don't get me started
no but i felt like you were on the verge
of emotion all night every time they
showed you it was like
you were almost there you know i'm i'm
i'm here tonight with you know sanaya
and demi
the girls who play venus and serena and
anjanu ellis um and venus is here with
her sister isha who's an executive
producer and it's like
it's just
all of these
women
you know that
see you get me started
i too will
no listen i get it i get it like just
even hear you talk about this film
through the process of it like i know
what your heart feels for for this
project and it's these people it's uh
it's all of these
all of these black women that i get to
protect
and
and shine a light on
you know um
you know across the generations and and
you know with venus and serena
um i know it's bad it's bad this is bad
no but it's like i just feel
um
you know
such a
responsibility you know it's like
it's like me and all black women
right my boyfriend tells me all the time
that he lives by this motto and it's ppl
that's protect provide and love
and like i feel that with you you know
and i love it it's like sanaya and demi
all night will introduce me to see you
know they well mr will they come mister
we do call you mr will mr will we have
to meet andrew garfield we can't leave
without meeting andrew garfield you know
and it's like
i don't know i just feel it's um
it's a responsibility i've always
wanted to shoulder i want to be that man
you know and it's like just across the
board i'm um
you know
and what about the man you portrayed
what do you think richard's got or think
about
no it's like i just get him i get him i
you know
um
you know that post world war ii
you know black man in america with a
dream and everybody tells you you crazy
you know
and my father was that guy
you know and just these big dreams and
no support at all you know
but do it anyway
you know
and do it in a different way than other
people
uh think you should do it
and just full on colliding with the
world out at the tip of that spear you
know when you come out victorious yeah
yeah yeah no that's beautiful sorry
sorry i know i'm tripping real quick
though
they showed in the audience denzel
jumped on his feet and was like clapping
and cheering for you no he he pulled me
up so you know me and me and denzel have
had some moments
you know over the past 15 years he's
always been a mentor for me you know and
he uh you know
he just pulled me up and and
he's he's seen a whole lot of iterations
of will smith like denzel is always one
of my first calls when stuff's not going
right
you know so
he's a good speed dial to have though
denzel
denzel uh he you know he's giving me
critical advice at really critical
moments and he just hugged me and he was
like you know he said this is your year
and he said i'm just so proud of the man
that you've become
you know
and then he grabbed a weight off of his
shoulders and said you got it
[Music]